das kratzt man sich die ganzen bilder
auf social media und fernsehen aber es
ist null komma null so wie es dann hier
wirklich also in wahrheit ist man kann
sich nicht nötig oder die gar nicht in
den vorstädten von sehen dass er nicht
[Musik]
so da der hamza letzten wagen mieten
muss bin ich alleine und werde ich zwei
drei mal zur kasse müssen weil kannst
gar nicht so viel in einen einkaufswagen
[Musik]
so ich war ein baumarten habe dann hier
zwei kartoffeln der seine gabel
natürlich mit ganz großen eimer und das
muss jetzt hier ein paar tüten und dann
kann es losgehen
33 stunden unterwegs als verzögert sich
ein bisschen wir sehr viel stau und
stockender verkehr ist aber sind gleich
dass ich glaube 20 minuten dann sind wir
da und dann können wir nicht die ganzen
also das ganze erste quartal
[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir kommen zu einem etwas
anderen region haben so ein bisschen
gerade in winzigen mitbekommen habt
dafür eine flutkatastrophe nicht nur
hier sondern in ihren times deutschland
den niederlanden belgien und diesmal so
kalt war wichtig für uns falls ich
genauso mit stausee drei stunden brennt
und haben uns überlegt wie er wir packen
einfach sachen die man essen kann und es
ist nicht viel was wir leisten aber man
nimmt sie so kam es dass es in der nähe
passiert warum muss man davon bald
stehen dies sind spenden auch immer sie
war richtig geld spenden erwarten denn
gedacht wir
einfach mal was gibt eine kleine gute
zahlen
nur wissen jetzt es ist letztlich ist
großartig dass wir jetzt auch in schutz
genommen
wir haben angenommen heute es geht aber
nicht darum jetzt irgendwie
jeder kann das mal
selbst hier jeder kasse machen ihr müsst
nichts mitbringen
klingt einfach gefördert so ein händler
mit und hilft in den namen und vor allem
meiner frau
brauchst du noch zwei helfen
ich denke ganz viele sagen ja und wenn
es nur ein paar eimer schlamm wenn die
man aus wohnungen draußen transportiert
heißt mein special also das ist auch
wenn man hier einmal antreten wird
das ist einfach aus überhaupt das ist
jetzt ein vergleich aber das ist ernst
gemeint das ist einfach krankheit frank
sinatra so was habe ich auch bis jetzt
noch nie erlebt dass die deutschen zum
inhalt anders wie den nachrichten dass
man sagt ja die brauchen keine hilfe ist
schon gar nicht jede helfende hand
[Musik]
so wir machen jetzt so dass wir einfach
eine mobile essen stationen sind an
sachwerten schrittgeschwindigkeit und
wir verteilen einfach dass es linie noch
alle sehr dankbar
aber ich muss sagen das buch gemacht
sehr knifflig
das katz ist man sich die ganzen bilder
auf social media im fernsehen sah es in
null komma null so wie es dann hier
wirklich also in wahrheit ist war kannst
es nicht machen
[Musik]
heftig und gar nicht in dem haus stecken
denn ich hasse dankbar die halle sind
hier basiert
und weil ich gehe auf in den
ganzheitlichen körper
dass ich dankbar
[Musik]
überhaupt nicht vorstellen hier nur ein
kleiner einblick möchte das hab und gut
denn heute nicht sein
so durfte sich auch anhört aber es
gehört halt mal irgendwie mund legte
[Musik]
so wir haben jetzt fast alles verteilt
und die menschen man sehr dankbar aber
auch richtig verletzt also man merkt und
meist auch den schock noch total an
übrigens nicht nur am sondern auch mein
schwager danke für deine hilfe
doch fleißig mit verteilt wir haben
jetzt ja damit seine minimalen anteil
ich glaube ein viertel oder so noch
übrig ist jetzt auch schon 20 uhr und
genau dann übermotiviert
das 1200 raps ganz viel obst müsliriegel
und so weiter aber wir haben auch als
antriebe verloren
die enisa die hat stimmt uns auch
kontaktiert und adressen durch gegeben
wo es am dringendsten notwendig ist und
damit zu folgen des vorfalls zu ihr und
bringen ihr den rest und sie wird den
rest morgen zum frische parteien das
geht auch ganz gut alles sehr sehr
frisch ist morgen ist übrigens das opfer
hat heute wo die ihr noch fleißig
gefasst ist und ja und ein paar werks
gesichert ist ja auch einiges übrig das
heißt gleich während der rückfahrt wird
das fasten gebrochen
[Musik]
so wir sind jetzt wieder zu hause die
bilder von gestern stecken noch richtig
tief in den knochen und ich glaube dass
das was online und was in den medien
gezeigt wird dass das spiel nicht mal
ansatzweise das wieder wie es in
wahrheit ist ihr habt diese ganzen
kisten gesehen so wasserkisten da hatte
hatte ich auch eine erklärung zu
bekommen von einigen zuschauerin die uns
auch vor ort koordiniert hat er sagte
dass dort die das dort apollinaris
bezüglich sinziger hat die ganzen kisten
da stehen wo genau und das wurde alles
noch mal alles wenn sie schon genug
außer das wurde alles noch mal runter
gespielt also die meisten
getränkegroßhändler wir haben aber ganz
viele kisten russischen ganz bestimmt
und die wollen komplett runter dazu noch
ein chaos geführt haben als wenn man
nicht ohnehin schon alle hände voll zu
tun und hört haben versucht noch
irgendwie ein bisschen was also was will
man da noch ein großartig weiß wie ich
meine es ist alle in sich vorstellt man
hat einfach nichts außer das was man an
hat in dem moment und das ist das
schlimme die haben von heute auf morgen
nichts familienangehörige sterben müssen
über 100 tote leider es sind über 1000
vermisste also ich will nicht wissen wie
die zahl am ende aussehen wird und warum
wir das ganze jetzt gefilmt warum man
wirklich die leute nicht nicht erkennt
ich sag mal so wenn ich in der situation
wäre dann will ich ungern niemand sehen
der mir hilft und arbeiten die kamera
folgt vor die nase setzt also bin ich
verstehe sehr okay kommt müsste jetzt
nur ein bisschen jetzt zeigen gehe ich
verteilt nein das habe ich nicht gemacht
ich hab wirklich gar nicht mit den
institutionen deswegen gefahren und da
die leute aufzunehmen sondern wirklich
um die tat oder um euch zu zeigen können
was tun
man kann was tun natürlich sollte man
jetzt nicht einfach irgendwann einpacken
und darunter fahren aber es gibt
facebook gruppen oder auch gerne unter
diesem video austauschen vielleicht
jemand der da vor ort auch hilft hätten
zb auch unsere kontaktperson an isar und
ihre familie die begrüßte nochmal an
euch wir haben uns geholfen ja uns auch
adressen gegeben also man kann jetzt
nicht einfach da runterfahren man musste
schon organisieren aber es wird auf
jeden fall hilfe gebraucht was ich nicht
verstehe warum warum wird gesagt es wird
keine hilfe gebraucht ich glaube es gibt
genug sachspenden was es niemals genug
geben kann sind wahrscheinlich
geldspenden oder
die hilfe und ja helfen aber ich glaube
auch die wir noch lange lange mit den
folgen zu kämpfen haben genau das
passiert halt bei uns also es sind jetzt
zwei autostunden gewebes ist quasi um
die ecke ist passiert sonst auch so was
in anderen ländern wo man eigentlich
nichts machen außer geld zu spenden
aber jetzt passiert ist bei uns und ich
finde da sollte man nicht wegschauen
weil es hätte auch uns passieren könnte
wenn ich in unserem gemütlichen
wohnzimmer sitzen und dann sieht man
auch wie gut es uns einfach gerade geht
jeder selbst das video hat in seinem
wohnzimmer im bett oder sonstwo guckt
sollte sich einfach mal glücklich
schätzen was wir haben ja auch noch so
schwankt vorkommen und das ist ja ein
bisschen türkisch zu bewusst ich schäme
mich dafür wie ich endlich diesen
wasserschaden hatte dass ich traurig
weil ich schäme mich dafür das ist nur
ein kleiner wasserschaden also ich werde
euch in die infobox einen spenden link
einsetzen falls ihr in euro übrig habt
oder mehr spendet super gerne und
ansonsten ganz viel kraft den
betroffenen und mein beileid an die
angehörigen
[Musik]